are you a believer that atheists are
treated fairly
all quorum Alpana wants to do is leave
Egypt the 23 year old engineering
student was facing three years in prison
for believing in nothing Alpana is an
atheist who is facing charges for
insulting Islam with his atheism he told
AFP all I want now is to leave Egypt
life is not possible for a theist here
between 2011 and 2013
42 defendants faced with the same
charges were ruled guilty all right so
I've done a ton of stories on atheist
and we've talked obviously many many
times about atheism you are my number
one atheist so you must represent all
atheists Canterbury is gonna be pissed
you're right there what am I
I feel like atheists are under attack in
a different way in the last like year or
so that's a lot in the United States but
of course a little bit all right what
what is people's problems with atheists
they take it as a personal insult if you
don't agree with them on this particular
subject and that's exactly what's
happening this guy you know he's an
atheist and they're saying that that is
an insult to Islam right but what about
that whole tolerance with religion thing
yeah that's supposed to be a thing right
yeah and the thing is is it's against
any of the three major Abrahamic
religions Christianity Judaism and Islam
yeah so if you were a Christian over
there it wouldn't be an insult but being
an atheist well you have to believe in
something so if you don't believe in
anything that's somehow oh that's it
that's an interesting take so right to
be an atheist would be the equivalent of
being just some other religion to say
you should be equally mad at that but
they are but they're not if you guys
it's almost like if you have something
it's better than nothing because at
least you're a part of a group similar
to mine yeah I mean what do you think I
feel like atheists are just constantly
under attack I see this in the media all
the time on Twitter all the time poober
always attacking new atheist which i
think is so weird because atheists
generally pretty good people not doing
they're not having a lot of rallies
rights don't get updated right no I
think I think similar to what she said I
think that you know people feel
personally attacked because it's
removing people's kind of last-ditch
effort at home
at like this possibility that there's
something else it's like they don't want
that possibility to be taken away from
them so it is them you know I really and
they take it very personally yeah I know
we did a story on this also which will
annotate above but can you explain the
difference between atheists give me some
basic definitions of atheist and theist
and agnostic can you give me a little
something here because people always
every time we do with something on this
people start arguing about just actually
what the words right and that's very
frustrating for me too because a lot of
people think that being an atheist means
that you know there is no God absolutely
1% sure certain and you have to say yes
and he was very angry about it always
yeah but that's not what it means at all
it just means that you don't believe in
God and it doesn't mean that you know
anything because that's what agnostic is
that's where that comes in because
Gnostic the root of that word is just it
means knowledge so to have to be
agnostic means you don't have knowledge
of something so I can say that I'm
agnostic I don't have knowledge of
whether or not there's a God but I'm
also an atheist so it's agnostic atheist
so you're an agnostic agnostic atheist
because you acknowledge you don't know
and then do that not knowing you're
saying you don't believe right and I
feel like everyone should technically
say that right yeah that's a gonna ask
you do most if you just call themselves
agnostic yes that I talk to you yeah
yeah why can't we get more tolerance out
of religion every religion why is it not
just about the atheism thing but in
general why you know religions supposed
to be tolerant and yet we see so much
war and hatred and whatever always
fermented maybe since the beginning of
time we've used religion as a scapegoat
for a barrage of other things whether it
be power or money or fear or things like
that you know it's just used as a tool
so I don't think that you know I just
feel like being like I said before
saying you're an atheist removes that
power to control and that power to have
that tool that's been used since the
beginning of yeah is this the weird
thing about social media and Facebook
and all that like on one hand it's like
freeing us all and it created the Arab
Spring and like has literally taken down
governments so it's amazing what it's
done in that part of the world and then
on the other hand now we're seeing the
backlash to it which is
is that this guy in Egypt Egypt and how
high of ours they get out the second
most aid of any country in the world
from the United States is being
persecuted for atheism so it's a
double-edged sword with social media -
right yeah I mean it can be and it's
just it's unfortunate that in any
situation he's in a country that's not
accepting of that but overall I feel
like it's important to have social media
because we can you know make positive
change through it yeah they theists need
to be more outraged like you're being
very calm right now this is one of you
I'm useful right like being attacked
yeah this is not uncommon yeah I mean I
hear stuff like this all the time yeah I
mean as much as it does make me mad and
angry it's just like one more thing you
know telling me and everyone else that's
an easy that is an atheist that you're
not okay that you're not normal that
you're somehow insulting your like
you're almost like over the outrage
that's what I said I mean like yeah I've
calmed down a lot whenever I first heard
of doing videos on YouTube I was like
girl very angry and yeah cussing but now
I'm a little bit more like okay I've
been talking about this for like four
years now
you know like what's new yeah Whitney I
feel like we need to play a game like
how to piss off an eight we're
sandwiching you with everybody's sister
now is the thing is that it's an
impossible battle to win because there's
just no proof in any directions or just
so we can sit here and just be at the
maddening you know you can just like
lose our minds over it so there's really
nothing you can do yeah is there nothing
you can do I know one thing you can do
you can comment